let's bring in laura trump fox news
contributor and daughter-in-law to the
former president good morning to you
laura
good morning guys it's great to be with
you good to have you on what did your
father-in-law what did your husband what
did you think what was your reaction
to seeing donald trump there on the
border
well i think it was fantastic to see
somebody actually go down and take
charge of the situation i mean
i'll tell you that president trump being
the former president
sure got a lot more accomplished in his
visit to the southern border than the
acting borders are kamala harris did
with her photo op trip to a place that
was 800 miles
away from where the real problem happens
to be down on the southern border so
i think the border patrol are happy that
they finally have
somebody there supporting them somebody
that is backing them up
it was certainly nice to hear somebody
talk about the fact
that we have to address the problem you
know you hear the democrats all day long
joe biden kamala harris try to tiptoe
around this and not talk about it
because it is a crisis
they don't want to admit it and they
don't want it to to get
you know be on their backs quite frankly
they're happy to have an open border
they ran
on an open border policy so thank
goodness the former president
is down there at the southern border
taking control of this situation
and what he said yesterday guys was so
accurate if they had just done nothing
it would have been better than than what
they've done
donald trump had it set up so well we
had record low border crossings under
his tenure as president
and now you see the disaster that has
ensued in a short amount of time
with the biden harris administration so
thank goodness somebody is paying
attention
former president trump well and you know
america
when he was running for president donald
trump said i'm going to do something
about the southern border i'm going to
build a wall
i'm going to make mexico pay for it i
could not get congress to pass the money
and so he declared a state of emergency
and redirected some money from the
pentagon that was the way he was able to
get the money to build
the portions of the wall that got built
laura
yeah that's right well look sometimes
you have to take matters into your own
hands and do what is best for the
american people as president
we knew that the democrats were never
going to buy into the idea of building a
wall
they uh deemed it to be a terrible idea
we know
that walls work and and you certainly
have seen the result
when donald trump was in office um and
all we need to do is complete a very
small
section of the wall i heard you guys
talking about it a few minutes ago
how sad is it that it's it's basically
been paid for we have all of the
supplies there everything is ready to go
yet the biden administration refuses
just to put up
these sections of well it's already done
i don't know why you would not want to
do what is right for the american people
i don't know why you would
wouldn't want to do what's right for the
people that are making this dangerous
journey
d d incentivize them to come here tell
them we got a wall
you're not going to be allowed into
america it seems to make sense but
again i don't expect to hear a whole lot
of that from the biden harris white
house
all right let's talk about what is
happening and that is uh
to fund the police and they're trying to
reverse and put it on republicans i
don't think anyone
uh looks at this seriously i don't think
it passed the laugh test
but one person is alarmed by it that
wasn't briefed on the fact that they
were supposed to
do a jujitsu with it is congressman
james clyburn
he was speaking out against to fund the
police he's always said this is one of
the dumbest things he's ever heard
in his life and here's his quote when
asked why he was endorsing a moderate
candidate
instead of the bernie sanders chief of
staff for martha fudge's seat
since she went to the white house said
this what i try to do is demonstrate by
precept and example
how we ought to proceed as a party when
i spoke out against sloganeering like
burn baby burn in the 1960s and defund
the police which i think is cutting the
throats of the party
i know exactly where my constituents are
they are against that
and i'm against that of course in south
carolina
they do not want to defund the police
you know that being from north carolina
yeah i agree with congressman clyburn
here he's exactly right
nobody wants to defund the police if
they are being
a reasonable and rational human being
the idea
that this was going to somehow help
anybody is absolutely
insane we have seen the result of what
defunding the police does it
actually hurts the most these inner city
communities that all of the blm rioters
who have been chanting defund the police
were supposedly trying to help
it is hurting their communities the most
we know that crime is skyrocketing
murders are up i mean it is it's a
really scary thing
to see happen in the united states of
america so yeah i guess he didn't get
the memo guys that uh all of a sudden
they were going to try and flip the
script
but he's exactly right defund the police
is an idiotic terrible idea
and you see the results of it now sadly
in so many of our big cities it's why
everybody
is leaving people are leaving new york
in droves people are leaving california
illinois
it's terrible to see but it is because
people do not want to live in a lawless
society plain
and simple and crime is through the roof
all right
uh you know i'm sure you were watching
earlier this week we showed the image of
gwen berry who
came in third uh over the weekend in the
hammer throw
at the olympic trials and during the
plane of the national anthem she turned
her back
uh you know and and she said she has
since said look i love my country
and there's been a lot of fallout from
it and as it turns out
uh apparently an old photo of her
holding an american flag went viral it
appears on her old
personal website touting her many
accomplishments there he is
she is quite proud about uh the american
flag
in that picture and laura remember she
said when she was asked about it she
said the national anthem has never
represented her but there she is in an
old photo
holding up the flag why the switch do
you think
yeah well i don't think anybody is
surprised to see this this is where the
internet actually
can come back and haunt you folks you
posted a photo
proudly holding the american flag and
yet you know we saw that ridiculous
display from her
whenever she came in third place there
how disrespectful that was to the other
women that she competed with
um look i think we all know that this
was a stunt this was an attempt
a very selfish attempt at that by her to
make a name for herself
to cause some waves i know she probably
wanted an endorsement from somebody of
some sort and she thought this
was the way to do it well how
disrespectful to america how
disrespectful
to our troops you know what if she wants
to compete
under the united states of america i
think she owes an apology to every
american
i think she owes an apology to every
soldier that has died
fighting for our flag to every family
that has lost someone who has died
fighting for our flag so
it's not that easy to just turn around
and say well i don't hate america
you very clearly disrespected every
american you disrespected the woman you
competed with
and you disrespected our flag so i think
it's very clear she did it for a selfish
reason
and it's disgusting to see we do not
need to have athletes like this
that our children are going to look up
to we need better representatives
for the united states go compete
somewhere else unless you want to
apologize she did the impossible she
escaped from north korea got through
mongolia had a rough time as a
sold off to slavery differently got
herself free in south korea and came
over to colombia
for a college education looked around
and cannot believe how ungrateful
americans are for the country that they
have we wanted to put gwen berry story
up next to
janmi park who's the north korean
defector from colombia
and now a human rights activist and
here's what she said
in north korea people who are actually
oppressed don't even know they're
oppressed
the fact that she's complaining
oppression and systemic racism
that she does not understand that she's
so privileged
she's literally spoiled being free so
much in this amazing country i was a
slave
i was sold in china in 2007 as a child
at 13 years old
the people actually going slavery under
chinese communist party in north korea
there is actual injustice and the fact
that she is complaining about this
country
the most tolerant country she doesn't
really understand i think his story
and laura you had mentioned the sponsor
turns out we discovered yesterday that
gwen berry is sponsored by a defund the
police uh
organization that apparently is getting
their money from
puma shoes yeah
there you go well that that young woman
you just heard from there the defector
from north korea
is exactly right go to any country in
the world other than america
you will not have it as good we are the
greatest country
in the world and i really hope that
people
start realizing that and stop falling
for the nonsense
we should all stand up proudly put our
hands over our hearts and respect our
american flag
i sure hope we see it at this year's
olympics and i'm sure we're going to see
it a lot this weekend with the fourth of
july
thank you very much for joining us live
thanks laura
thanks guys